good morning hank it's tuesday today is
the first day of the turtles all the way
down movie shoot greetings from you know
i'm not actually sure i'm allowed to say
where greetings from kovid test living
the dream isaac am i allowed to say like
what city we're filming in
greetings from cincinnati this is isaac
he's producing the movie say hi isaac
all right there's no place i'd rather be
pay no attention to the costume change
it's definitely not a continuity error
so four things i always forget about
watching movies get made first i always
feel like i'm in the way like a movie
set is basically a large construction
site and
i don't know how to do construction
scaffolding and ladders and lights are
always moving this way and that and i
somehow managed to be in the way of that
like hundreds of times every day but
everyone's always really nice about it
they don't like yell at me or anything
they just say points which is movie
speak for you're about to get hit by
something pointy second when i watch
movies i always think like this is
taking place in a very beautiful and
sophisticated location but then like
right now for instance my view is
currently of a dumpster it's a very
cinematic dumpster but but it is a
dumpster third there are so many people
here and they're all busy they're all
doing stuff 12 hours a day the only
person who's not busy
is me and lastly on that front it is
impossible to put into words how amazing
it is to have all of these people
pouring their time and talent and love
into this story earlier today the
movie's first assistant director mary
said we're trying to 3d print your
imagination and that really is how it
feels i have attempted to move to a
place out of the whim so listen hank i i
am not allowed to tell you what we are
shooting today but i can tell you a
story so part of my book turtles all the
way down is set it a chuck e cheese
which is like an american chain of
children's fun places their mascot is a
mouse whose government name i'm not
making this up is charles entertainment
cheese so the nice people making the
turtles all the way down movie reached
out to chuck e cheese to request
permission to film in one of their
esteemed establishments and chuck e
cheese responded that that was not going
to happen i'm not going to read you
their exact response partly because i
want to avoid spoilers and partly
because i'm a little worried i might get
sued but suffice it to say that chuck e
cheese was not happy with my portrayal
of their institution in turtles all the
way down just for the record of course
look it's a work of fiction but i stand
by
most of my portrayal like i think there
probably is p in the ball pit i think
there is p in most ball pits i mean for
the record i think there's p in almost
everything i think that's a leonard
cohen lyric so anyway i'm not allowed to
tell you what we're filming today but i
can tell you that it's not at a chuck e
cheese but i actually think what's
happening instead might be better and
more wonderful this has just been the
most amazing day isabella merced who is
playing aza understands that character
so so deeply cree who's playing daisy is
amazing the director hannah marks has
read the book like more than i have and
loves it so much and cares about it so
much so yeah i just feel so lucky and
grateful today but the other thing i'm
thinking is that this is only happening
because so many people read and cared
about the book because they responded
with such generosity to the book's
exploration of anxiety and obsessive
thinking disorders and free will and its
other themes and i think everybody here
is committed to making a movie that
spreads the same ideas that the book did
that people's pain is real and deserves
attention and validation but that there
is also hope
even when your brain tells you there
isn't i am very glad i lived through
some hard days hank so that i could have
this one
hank i'll see you on friday